hi my name is Itamar and again i'll be
talking about what to do when your data
doesn't fit in memory but before I start
talking about that I just as a prelude
wanted to remind everyone of the most
important question you should be asking
about any software project which is
whether that software project should be
written at all if the software you're
writing hurts people hurts the
environment the better you are at the
job the more damage you're doing and so
it's very important to ask this first if
you're working a large organization
there's probably some employee group
that's trying to push your organization
in that direction for example I know
Microsoft has a group called Microsoft
workers for good there's other groups
and other large organizations so for the
rest of my talk I'm assuming that you've
asked yourself use question you've said
yes I'm not causing more damage they
were all there writing the software ok
this is better
so the problem we'll be talking about
for the rest of talk and what to do and
you have too much data so you've written
some code it's analyzing some data and
when you load some test data small
amount everything works fine but then
when you load the file the real data
your program crashes and so what's going
on is you have let's say 60 megabytes of
RAM and your laptop your data file is a
hundred Rica bytes of RAM if you load
more data than you have RAM at some
point you try to allocate some memory
for the operating system the operating
system says nope sorry we're out and
your program crashes and what you do
next
so one solution is a big data cluster
and all you'll have to do is buy a whole
bunch of computers you just kind of week
setting it up there's a decent chance
you'll have to learn a completely new
API not always but often and then if
you're using a new API you have to
rewrite all of your code and so this
isn't a very appealing approach if you
can avoid it and so in many situations
there is a simpler easier way and I'm
going to constrain the solution space to
the case where you have a single
computer just like you usually do
minimal setup and only you have to spend
hours and hours or days and days setting
up a system and for the most part the
ideal is that you should be able to use
the existing libraries you're using the
existing code you're using and it may be
that you'll have to make some small
changes you do have
this problem but in many cases you don't
need a big data cluster you can process
all the data you need to on your own
computer and before we go to the
solutions it's worth asking why do we
need memory at all memory RAM is a thing
that you can read and write to your hard
drive is a thing that you can read and
write to so why does your computer have
two completely different ways of storing
data and the wrong that's relevant to
our purposes is that even solid-state
hard drives which are the newer hard
drive technology it's much faster than
the old kind of hard drive which would
physically spin around even these newer
faster hard drives are much much slower
than your RAM something like 160 times
slower so if you were to try to do your
computation without using Ram just by
reading and writing for disk your data
processing would be much much slower and
it would probably take much longer than
you're willing to take and so we need to
use Ram because RAM is the storage we
have that is that lets you do the read
and write data quickly so the first
solution in many ways the easiest is to
throw more money at the problem so if I
just went in priced out a workstation
six core CPU 64 gigabytes of RAM about a
thousand dollars I didn't do any
research I didn't try to find cheaper
deals I'm shooting at more memory for
less money but you can spend a thousand
dollars and now you have a new machine
of 64 gigabytes of RAM I mean if that's
enough to fit your data in memory you're
done you don't really have to listen to
rest of talk you can just go and run
your program and everything will work
similarly if buying is not an option or
you only need to run this computation
once you can go to your cloud vendor
this is a quote from Mac Microsoft Azure
I believe and they will have servers
with a lot of RAM so this example is
four hundred thirty two gigabytes of RAM
64 cores and it's three dollars 60 cents
an hour and so if you're only gonna be
running your computation for four hours
this is a great deal you just spin up in
your virtual machine and saw your
software running as normal you're done
however this is not always going to
solve all of your problems
it may be that your data is so big that
you can't realistically buy enough RAM
in any foreign shape or form to process
it and fit it on memory it may also be
that the cumulative costs of processing
lots of data over time means that you
really want to spend some time reducing
your memory usage so at one point at one
job I did the calculation and if we were
to go into production with the compute
time that we had at the time on the
cloud machines we were to spend all of
our revenue paying our cloud vendor and
none of it would have been left over for
profit or for paying my salary so I
punch of time both reducing the
computation time but also reducing the
memory usage a lot so we could run more
data on a single machine so if you can't
add more RAM the other solution is to
use less ram by writing some software
there are three techniques that we'll be
covering and I'm going to talk about
what they each mean in detail over the
course of this talk just so you have a
road map that three techniques are
compression compressing our data
processing your data in chunks one chunk
at a time or maybe some processing some
of the chunks at parallel and finally
indexing your data so you only load the
data that you actually care about and
for the rest of the talk I'm going to be
showing examples of how both defining
these techniques and showing examples
have used these techniques of to
libraries numpy and pandas the
techniques I'm showing are not
exhaustive there are other ways you can
do this both of them bind pandas and
with other libraries and in addition the
particular structure of your data and
processing or doing means that you might
be able to do something specific to your
data for example it's often possible to
come up with ways to compress your data
that are particular to your particular
data set so this is not exhaustive this
is just a lot of examples so you can get
started and so that you know what to
look for when you're processing your
data will start with compression and
compression is taking the same data and
are presenting it with less memory you
can have lossless compression where you
have the exact same data just in a
different store in a different way or
you can have lossy compression where
you're losing some
details but details that don't actually
matter for your final results and maybe
you can drop a few the details and no
one will ever notice you look at the
same basic results it doesn't matter
and when I say compression you might be
thinking of sound like a zip file or
gzip where you have a compressed file on
disk that's not what I'm talking about
because those are ways to compress your
data as it's stored on disk when you
load it into memory you're gonna
uncompress that zip file what I'm
talking about is compressing the
presentation once you've loaded the data
into memory we'll start with numpy so in
case you're not familiar numpy is a
library python for processing arrays we
can do various operations on arrays and
each array has a data type you can have
an array of integers you can have array
of floats and integers come in different
sizes so you might have a 16-bit integer
or you can install star valid excuse me
you can store values between zero and
about 65,000 you can have a 64-bit
integer where you can store values
between zero and a very large number but
64-bit integers while they let you store
much larger numbers they also
correspondingly use more memory so a
64-bit integer as you would expect uses
four times as much memory than a 16-bit
integer because it's using four times as
many bits in RAM that means is if your
data can fit into a smaller data type if
you know that integers are never gonna
be higher than 65,000 you don't need
64-bit integer 16-bit integers will do
fine and your memory usage will be cut
by 75% let's see an example
I'm create an array I can create two
arrays they're two dimensional arrays
each one's 1024 by thousand 24 and the
first array is a array of unsigned
64-bit integers and the second array is
an array of 16-bit unsigned integers we
can look using the invites attribute how
much memory they're using and as you
would expect the array that uses 64-bit
integers uses four times as much memory
as the 16-bit integer right so if your
numbers are no higher than 65,000
there's no point in using anything more
than 16-bit and you would just reduce
your memory usage without changing any
other part of your code except this one
line
another technique you can use a sparse
arrays typically if you're storing data
an array you allocate a chunk of memory
that has basically maps one to one with
the contents of the array but oftentimes
your array is mostly can be full of
zeros 0 0 0 0 and occasionally there
will be a little bit of data that's not
0 for example if you think of a star map
much of the night sky will have nothing
in it and at some locations there will
be a star with maybe a brightness and so
why race time why sorry why a star my
race memory storing all those zeros or
you can just say the default is 0 and
will only store the information that's
different than 0 and sparse is a library
this URL that implements this idea and
it interoperates in the numpy api's it
also supports a subset of a numpy a P I
so you can often just swap it in
depending on your interactions and it
has different representations of sparse
arrays because depending on the
structure of your data there's different
ways to compress it into a sparse array
and in this example we'll be using a
coordinate sparse array where what it
stores is the coordinate of where the
values are different than 0 for example
you might say at X 3 y 400 there's value
3 and at X 500 y - there's value 2 and
1/2 and so you can store and if you
think about stars is a reasonable way to
distort our locations you store the X Y
location and your large image and the
rest of it is just presumed to be 0 so
we created an array thousand 24 by
thousand 24 it's two-dimensional and we
fill it we're filling it with random
values uniformly distributed between 0 &
1 then we say anything that's less than
0.9 we're gonna set to 0 it was an
example from the sparse documentation by
the way so you can find it there as well
and so we're basically we're saying is
this array is 90% zeros only 10% of it
is not 0 so we can convert it into a
sparse array and if we compare the
memory usage as you would expect the
sparse array is using much less memory
because it doesn't have to use lots of
RAM to store all those zeros
you can only use this technique if a
significant amount of your data is zeros
and depending on the structure and shape
of your data you might need different
sparse representations or maybe sparse
orbit is it this farce library's
representations aren't gonna be good
enough and you'll have to come up with
your own custom way of compressing that
uses this basic idea you can save a lot
of memory by not storing redundant
information like all your zeros so next
we're going to switch to pandas and just
in case you're not familiar pandas
stores what's called data frames which
are tables and each table each column in
the table has a particular type so you
can think of a CSV or one column in the
CSV the string and another column is an
integer and so on so when you load a CSV
pandas will make a guess about what the
type of that column is so if it sees
that all the values in the in that CSV
in a particular column are what looks
like integers it will say oh I bet this
as an integer and by default it will use
64-bit integers to represent that column
so again if we know that this column and
this CSV is only going to have integer
values that are no higher than 65,000 we
don't need a 64-bit integer we need a
16-bit integer and so when we load the
CSV there's a way to tell pandas with a
d-types
keyword argument saying this column gets
this D type can also be useful if pandas
is guessing wrong in this case we're
just using it to reduce the memory usage
and so you can see if we just load this
USB by default the this column uses
around 40,000 bytes but if we load it
with a 16-bit integer as the D type is
that how much memory is used to store
each value in the column then it uses
only a quarter as much memory and it may
be that we that we know that this is
gonna fit it fit in 60 minute in the
church there's no point in wasting that
memory so again just a one-line change
that was compression and the next
technique we're going to talk about is
chunking so chunking means we're gonna
load the data and we're not to load all
of it into memory at once we're gonna
operate on one chunk at a time and
eventually process all the data that way
and so the basic intuition is most that
may be at most the time but much of the
time when you're processing your data
the processing you're doing doesn't
require loading all the data at once so
if you think about finding the maximum
value of an array one thing you can do
is you can load the whole array into
memory and find the maximum on that or
you can split your array into two halves
you can find the maximum in the first
half and find the maximum the second
half and then the maximum of the whole
array is the maximum of the maximum of
those two chunks and so we didn't need
to load if we use this approach we don't
have to load the whole arrange of memory
we can just use parts of it and we'll
still get the correct answer the maximum
so if you're dealing with numpy arrays
one way to be able to process your data
and show this to you is a library called
czar if you bought the library in a
storage format and Czar lets you store
very large arrays on disk and then load
only part of that array and when you
load only part of an array only that
part of the array is loaded into memory
and so you can load part of an array you
can read it you might want to modify it
and write it back and then you only that
part needs to be written out and so you
that allows you to very easily operate
only on particular chunks of your very
large array so in this example we are
creating in a one-dimensional array of
length 1000 with chunks on disk of
length 1 sorry the array is length of 1
million but it'll be stored in disk and
chunks of a thousand so if you load it
on these boundaries it only has to load
that chunk on disk and then we're gonna
say the maximum of this array is the
maximum of all the chunks which we're
going to load one by one and we'll load
a chunk we'll figure out its maximum and
we'll have a list of neck of the maxes
of those chunks and then we'll do the
max overall max of all the maxes of the
chunks --is of the chunks so you can
figure out the maximum without having to
load the whole array into memory and if
you look at the type of the Czar array
object it is a different type than numpy
array it's not actually an array it's
just a pointer to the storage on disk
you don't actually use any memory until
you load a sub slice part of the array
into memory and then you have a normal
in Empire I and you can run all your
normal numpy code if you want you can
write it back to the Tsar but when you
load part of the array you're only
loading that particular part into memory
you don't have to worry about loading
the whole giant array from disk into
memory andas also supports chunking and
in pandas it's actually built-in you
don't have to use an external library so
beforehand we saw how you can load a CSV
and if you load a CSV the whole thing
with load to memory would get back a
data frame however you can also tell
pandas to load your CSV in chunks you
tell I want to chunk size of a hundred
and that means instead of giving you one
data frame it'll give you an iterator of
data frames each one of the hundred
lines 100 rows from your CSV and so you
can iterate over the result with a for
loop and each time you'll get next
hundred lines as a separate chunk so you
don't have to load the whole CSV into
memory at the same time so in this case
again we're calculating a maximum in
this case the maximum of one of the
columns and so we load each chunk each
one of only a hundred rows at a time and
we figure out if the maximum this chunk
is bigger than the overall max we've
calculated so far and we're done with a
loop we found the maximum of the whole
column and we've done it without having
to load the whole CSV into memory the
only loaded 100 lines at a time into
memory so now I'm gonna go in a short
digression but a useful one so we've
been talking about processing your data
in chunks so you load a hundred lines
figure out their maximum load underlines
figure out their maximum and if you
think about it calculating the maximum
chunk a and calculating that the maximum
of chunk B those are completely distinct
operations chunk a is calculation
doesn't have to know anything in all but
chunkies calculation at the same time
your computer probably has multiple CPUs
multiple cores you can do calculations
in parallel and it won't and your
computer will be able to handle it up to
the number of cores your computer has
you saw earlier a virtual machine that
had 64 cores so you can use 64
operations in parallel and so that means
if we're ready processing our data in
chunks we have the opportunity to
process those chunks in parallel and
then won't reduce our memory usage but
it will allow us to run or I'll
calculate or run all of our calculations
much faster in wall clock time because
instead of doing 100
at a time we can do 400 lines at a time
by doing 4 chunks in parallel on
different CPUs and one difference
between normal operation we've been
seeing so far and parallelism is that if
you're doing multiple chunks in parallel
you need to shrink down your chunk size
you can imagine that if you have 64
gigabytes of RAM you can say we'll leave
aside 4 gigabytes of RAM just for the
operating system and all the other stuff
that's running when we use 60 gigabytes
of RAM to process our data so if you're
only processing one chunk at a time you
have up to 60 gigabytes of RAM with
which to process each chunk if however
you're doing 4 chunks at a time in
parallel you're loading four times you
would be loading four times as much data
at a time and so you need to shrink your
chunk size down accordingly and so now
you're you each each chunk can only have
15 gigabytes of RAM and so you just have
to use smaller chunks there's something
to think about when you're doing
parallelism parallelism and one easy way
to do parallel computation it was the
desk library and I'm not gonna go into
much detail here I'm just mentioning it
and giving a couple of slides about it
desk lets you run parallel computations
in one computer you can also scale it up
to multiple computers and you can just
give an arbitrary Python code but it
also emulates the numpy API so you can
write code that looks very much like
normal numpy code and then tell the desk
okay this is the code I want to run
please do it in parallel for me using
chunking behind the scenes so we can
compare these two bits of code and one
of them I'm just opening as R and I'm
running a maximum on it using numpy and
that runs in about 1.1 seconds and in
the second example I'm asking desc to do
the same thing so I'm telling tasks I'm
going to ask you to load this R and then
run max on it now that I've told you
what the computation is please run that
computation with for workers in parallel
and now it runs in 300 milliseconds so
about a quarter of the time because
we're using four workers and it's only
one or two extra lines of code and once
you're getting to more complex
calculations it's not quite as simple
but in many cases desk will let you very
truly take some numpy code i've
in parallel using chunks and just get
results back faster because your
computer can utilize all of its course
similarly dest emulates the panda's API
so you can take your panda's code and I
tell desc to run it in parallel using
chunked processing and get faster
results so now that we're done with
chunking when the small aside about
parallelism we'll talk about a third
technique indexing and indexing is used
when you need to load a subset of the
data so imagine that you're reading a
book and you want to read only those
parts of the book that are about
aardvarks so you could read the whole
book from beginning to end and find all
the mentions of aardvarks or you can go
to the back of the book or hopefully
there's an index lookup aardvarks and
the index and say it'll tell you
aardvarks are mentioned on page 100 and
135 and then you only have to read those
two pages and so an index is a summary
of the data telling you where to find
the data that you care about and choose
you much smaller than the overall data
so you can often fit in memory or at
least it's faster to load from disk and
it allows you to only load the data that
you are actually interested in and since
we talked about chunking before we
talking about indexing now it's worth
sort of emphasizing the difference
between them chunking means loading all
of the data you it's true the only
loading part of it but your goal is to
eventually load all the data and you're
just loading a chunk by chunk because
you don't have enough memory and so if
you're asking the question what's the
longest word in this book you are going
to have to go through the whole book
there's no other solution but you don't
have to load the whole book into memory
you can load it page by page indexing
allows you to answer questions where you
know you only need part of the data so
how much money did we spend in July you
don't care about June you don't care
about February you don't care about
August you only care about July and so
there's no point and loading any of the
data from February now you don't
technically need indexing as you'll see
in a following slide you can just load
all the data and then filter out
everything that's not from July that
comes with its own set of problems in
practice you often use indexing and
chunking together so it
you used indexing to only find the data
for July it may be that that data is
still too big to fit in memory at which
point you might load it using chunking
loading it let's say one day at a time
so the simpler solution for chunking is
a bunch of files in a directory you are
loading you know that you're gonna be
loading data based on the which month
the data is from so you make a naming
scheme where the data for a particular
month has a particular name on the file
system and then your directory listing
is basically your index if you want the
data for April you load 2019 - April
let's CSV and you don't have to load any
of the data from the other months
because there are different files this
is a simplest form of an index might be
enough but often you need something a
bit more complicated than that so let's
take a look an example so I'm gonna
start with an example that doesn't use
indexing and then I'm gonna rewrite it
to use indexing the example is you are
looking at voter registration records
you're running some sort of political
campaign you want to reach voters and so
you want to find which voters live on a
particular street for your campaigning
and you're going to be running this
query a lot because today are
campaigning in this neighborhood so you
need to load to these streets
Temari or containing the next name Road
you like to learn different you need to
visit different streets and so you're
gonna be running this query a lot and so
in our initial implementation we load
the whole CSV and it's really big
because it's a New York voter
registration records there's a lot of
people in New York and so you can't load
it all into memory you're loading it in
chunks so we're gonna load it that panda
data frame in chunks and for each trunk
each chunk we're gonna filter it down to
only those rows where the street matches
the street name we care about and we're
going to concatenate all those data
frames and return them and then we'll
get a data frame that has other rows
where the street matches whatever Street
we care about so that's how you would
implemented with chunking without
indexing so next we're going to see how
we might implement this query only using
an index and we're because we're running
this query a bunch of a bunch of times
we're going to actually process it a
little bit to build the index and we're
gonna store our data instead of a CSV
file we're gonna
it into a database file and in
particular we're going to use the sequel
Lite database
unlike saying like Postgres or my sequel
or other or Oracle database the sequel
Lite database is just the library you
can just import it into Python it's
built into Python just stores its data
in a file so it's much operationally
much easier to run you're not running a
server you're just importing a library
and running some code but it's still
actually a very powerful database or
when you create a database and then
we're going to load in our CSV and read
it in chunks and then as we load a chunk
we are gonna tell pandas pandas please
write these rows to the database into
the voters table and if the table
already exists append these rows so
pandas will automatically create the
table on the sequel Lite database you
don't have to think about how it's going
to be stored I don't know what this
table structure is I just ran the code
and pandas did it for me
so you don't have to do you don't really
have to think about very much how its
structure in the database you're just
having pandas do all the work for you
once you loaded all the records into
this database into this file you then
tell the sequel ID database I want you
to create an index on the voters table
on the street column and you can create
multiple indexes so if you end up
running queries that require different
index different columns in your table
you can create an index for that and get
fast queries you're not restricted to
one index and you can also do even do
indexes across multiple columns that
sort of thing and then we close our
database so now we have populated a
sequel Lite database that has our voter
registration records and it has an index
on the street column and so now we can
implement our function for getting the
voters for a particular street we open
our database and then we construct a
sequel query saying please load all the
data select star from the voters table
where the street equals whatever value
what this function was called with as an
aside this code has a sequel injection
attack you should not use normal string
manipulation functions to create sequel
queries you should use something like
the sequel alchemy library consider this
way so it's more readable so you run
this query and you have this query and
then you tell pandas this sequel query
please run it
against this database and give me the
resulting data frame so when you run the
sequel query sequel it-- is going to
look at it separately and say if you're
looking for third Avenue I know where in
the database the records for 30 a venue
are I don't have to go through the whole
database I have this index that tell me
where to find only the data you care
about and then it'll only give panda as
the data that that results of that query
so we are only loading the rows we
actually care about into memory so now
we can compare these two techniques I'm
using the Cambridge Massachusetts voters
registration records because I happen to
have them the memory usage is a little
bit different than two techniques and
the chunking technique memory usage was
the thousand rows the chunk size that we
loaded for each chunk we loaded plus the
overall result that we returned he found
10,000 records then we have to store
memory for the results in the sequel I'd
method when we're using indexing the
amount man we had to use was the memory
used to store the index and again we
have we need memory allocated for the
overall results of our queries B in both
cases the index is going to be much
smaller than the overall file so I would
expect in both cases certainly with
Cambridge but even in New York I would
expect the index the ultimate in memory
just fine and so you're not going to be
running out of memory the more so both
of these techniques work in terms of
reducing memory usage however the more
dramatic difference is in the time it
took to run the query in the example
where we used chunking where we had to
load the whole CSV and then filter out
every single row that didn't match her
query it took us 570 milliseconds in the
case where we had an index where we only
had to load the rows that exactly match
our query it took 10 milliseconds and so
our query ran much much faster because
we weren't wasting time filtering our
data we don't care about so we've
reduced our memory usage but also
because we have an index that helps us
find things quickly we've also reduced
the time it takes to run the query
so those are our three techniques so
what about a few what if you're using
some other library for not using numpy
is not using pandas you'll be facing the
same route causes memory is fast so you
need to do your computation memory it's
also expensive so you may not be able to
buy enough memory to fit all your data
in memory disk is cheap you can get
enough disk space usually to fit all
your data but disk is slow so you can't
do your computation off your disk and
even because you're facing the same
underlying problems you also have the
same basic solutions which are
compression chunking maybe with
parallelism if you can and indexing and
now that you know about these three
techniques whenever using your database
and ever use a new library you know what
to look for you know oh I I'm using too
much memory how can I compress it oh I
can't fit in memory how can i load in
chunks oh I need to look up data only
associative data how do I do an index
those techniques will recur again again
in different libraries and technologies
that you use you should also not forget
about the solution of just spending
money you might be able to just your
time is probably much more valuable than
the the Mon money takes to buy a new
computer and so as a starting point you
might you should just go price out how
much you would cost to buy a computer
with more RAM or if you already have a
workstation it's easier to add memory to
it than a laptop and if you want to
learn more there are a number of talks
at the conference that do deep dives at
the subsets of the of these topics
there's a talk about Tsar versus hdf5
industry f5 is a format a little bit
similar to Tsar and that lets you store
large arrays but it's also somewhat more
flexible and more powerful you can also
use it with pandas there's a talk about
improving the efficiency of your big
data application which is about more
sophisticated compression techniques and
I've talked about here and there's a
talk about desk in particular using desk
with GPUs but I think it also tutorial
separately but just I think my guess is
it's more broadly you'll learn a little
bit what more about how to use desk and
what it does
thank you for coming you can find the
slides for the stock at this URL Python
cut Python speed comm a slash PI data 19
this is my email this is my Twitter
account if you've enjoyed your talk this
talk if you think like you've learned
something I provide training so if you
think I can help your data scientists on
your team improve their technical skills
please talk to me and I think we have
time for maybe three minutes of
questions and then afterwards all of the
outside so the question is what can you
do for lossy compression and that's in
many ways very domain-specific because
what the data you can you're ok losing
depends on the kind of data you're
processing I'm not really sure what
lossy compression would be for a voter
registration database I guess you can
filter out people who all live in the
same address because you can only knock
on one door for images you can think
about JPEG compression where you lose
some of the details but at least to the
human eye much of the time you won't
notice a difference and so in some cases
you can compress your data that way I
when I was processing image data I was
considering a scheme where one part of
the data would be stored as lossy
compression of an image and then the
parts of the image that we knew are
interesting would be stored with the
original data so we had the full amount
of data you can also combine the two so
it's lossy compression is very specific
to your domain and what details you know
are not meaningful and you can just drop
so it sounds like the indexing technique
that you just really useful when you
refresh them like earlier that day then
you run the query multiple times later
but not so much for like up if you need
to pawn the data like on right because
then you still have to load in the
sequel knife database I've done queried
so yeah so the question is is it useful
to Canada's indexing help you when
you're look when you're processing data
on the fly live yeah so indexing doesn't
help you the indexing is you have this
unchanging data set you're doing
multiple queries against and so how do
you efficiently load only parts of it
into memory it's or load them with
chunking if you're processing data live
I yeah it's not going to help you okay
if again if you want to talk to me
that's my email and I will be outside